los 200 policías que esta mañana
registraban la sede de la web stand news
y que detenían a los directivos en sus
domicilios simbolizan por un lado los
ataques a la libertad de prensa y por el
otro la deriva hong kong esa después de
la aprobación de la ley de seguridad
nacional seis personas han sido
detenidas entre ellos el jefe de
redacción actual y su predecesor así
como antiguos miembros del consejo de
dirección como la célebre cantante
denisse jo o la antigua parlamentaria
margaret a todos han sido acusados de
publicar materiales sediciosos la
detención de personas que ya se habían
desvinculado sugiere que el gobierno ni
perdona ni olvida tampoco han servido
todas las precauciones el medio en junio
había borrado muchos de los comentarios
de su web y dejado de aceptar donaciones
privadas esas medidas fueron adoptadas
después del cierre de la app el daily el
medio más fragoroso y popular de hong
kong que sucumbió a las embestidas
legales y a la congelación de bienes su
fundador el célebre magnate jimmy lai
encadena sentencias condenatorias que la
aseguran larga estancia en la cárcel la
libertad de prensa es una de las
principales víctimas de la ley de
seguridad nacional el gobierno insiste
en que sigue intacta pero una reciente
encuesta en el club de corresponsales
extranjeros de hong kong sugería que la
mitad ya planea su marcha